[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian
sieers guten Abend ihn allen aus
Deutschlands Wirtschaft heute eine
schlechte und eine gute Nachricht wobei
ich leider gleich wieder einschränken
muss so richtig gut ist auch die gute
Nachricht nicht welche also zuerst
beginnen wir vielleicht mit der
schlechten Deutschland im Abschwung die
führenden Forschungsinstitute haben ihre
Prognose zur Wirtschaftsentwicklung
kräftig heruntergeschraubt die deutsche
Wirtschaft schrumpft und die Gründe sind
ganz offenbar hausgemacht denn um uns
herum geht es in den anderen großen
Volkswirtschaften international überall
aufwärts schuld daran sei auch die
Bundesregierung deren Politik
Unternehmen und Haushalte Zitat massiv
verunsichert habe und dann die halbgute
Nachricht heute die Inflation ist immer
noch hoch aber mit kräftiger Tendenz zum
besseren sie ist jetzt auf dem
niedrigsten Stand seit Beginn des
russischen Krieges gegen die Ukraine
alle Details von Benjamin
Jalowski in unseren Supermärkten ist die
gute Nachricht bisher leider noch kaum
angekommen die Preise für Lebensmittel
steigen weiter insgesamt aber eine
deutliche Entwarnung bei der Inflation
die Preissteigerung hatte seit September
21 stark zugelegt und erreicht erst
jetzt wieder den Wert vom Frühjahr 22
4,5%. mit den Preisen also alles wieder
gut alles wieder gut ist vielleicht ein
bisschen viel gesagt wir haben natürlich
immer noch hohe Preise sie steigen jetzt
bloß nicht mehr weiter das hat
einerseits mit Sondereffekten zu tun das
Auslauf euroticket z.B aber es hat auch
damit zu tun dass eben dieser
energiepreisschock der ja am Anfang von
allem stand dass der eben jetzt aus dem
Daten wirklich verschwindet die
Energiepreise Strom und Gas sinken
spürbar damit auch die
Lebensmittelpreise allmählich und das
hat die Inflationsrate nach unten
gedrückt als diese Herren und Dame am
Vormittag vor die Presse treten haben
sie trotzdem schwere Nachrichten im
Gepäck die führenden
Wirtschaftsinstitute sind sich sicher
mit Deutschlands Wirtschaft geht's etwas
Berg ab alles allem wird das
Bruttoinlandsprodukt im Jahr 2023 um
0,6% sinken damit revidieren die
Institute ihre Prognose vom frühahr 2023
kräftig um 0,9% Punkte nach unten die
Gründe für den Abschwung liegen zum
einen in der schwierigen
weltwirtschaftlichen Lage für
deutschland als Exportnation besonders
heikel die Experten ermahnen aber auch
die deutsche Regierung so seien
angedachte Subventionen für
energieintensive Unternehmen falsch
es löst sich nicht dadurch dass man für
Teile der Verbraucher hier mit neuen
Subventionen
hantiert und deshalb geht es eben auch
nicht auf dass man dann ausgerechnet
energieintensive Branchen am Standort
halten will oder gar neue anziehen
möchte sinkendes Wirtschaftswachstum gab
es in Deutschland in den vergangenen 30
Jahren schon mehrfach am heftigsten in
der Finanzkrise und während
Corona das unser Wohlstand aber nicht
nur von der Wirtschaftskraft sondern
auch unserem gesellschaftlichen Klima
abhängt war heute ein überraschend
klarer Appell der Wirtschaftsexperten
die bekannte Selbstverständlichkeit
unserer Werte im Miteinander sei
bedroht seit einiger Zeit gewinnt
extremes Gedankengut an Boden welches
diese Selbstverständlichkeiten in Frage
stellt mögen die unmittelbaren
Konjunkturrisiken dieser Tendenz auch
begrenzt sein so gehen von ihr doch
erhebliche Risiken für die langfristigen
Wachstums und wohlstandsaussicht icht
aus mit der Wirtschaft wird es nächstes
Jahr wohl langsam wieder aufwärts gehen
Prognose
1,3% bleibt zu hoffen dass dies auch für
unser Miteinander
gilt ja das ist schon interessant was
die Forschungsinstitute wir haben es
gerade kurz gehört da ganz explizit
anmerken die große Sorge um das
gesellschaftliche Klima in Deutschland
ich zitiere noch mal derzeit Gerät etwas
in Gefahr das bis vor kurzem in
Deutschland selbstverständlich war
nämlich ein gesellschaftliches Klima das
Unternehmen und Haushalten das Vertrauen
gibt dass die Grundregeln unserer
Gesellschaft allgemein akzeptiert werden
Zitat Ende frank betetmann ist bei uns
unser Wirtschaftsexperte guten Abend
Frank das ist ja schon einigermaßen
bemerkenswert was mahnen denn die
Forscher da an kann man das auf diese
Grundformel bringen Extremismus ist auch
schlecht für die Geldbeutel kann man im
Grunde genommen so sagen eigentlich
geht's ja um Selbstverständlichkeiten
respektvoller Umgang miteinander Respekt
gegen über Eigentum wenn diese Dinge
nicht mehr gegeben sind weil das
gesellschaftliche Klima das nicht mehr
hergibt dann haben wir hier ein Problem
dann kriegen wir nämlich keine
Investoren mehr ins Land wir kriegen
auch keine ausländischen Fachkräfte mehr
ins Land oder nur noch weniger beides
brauchen wir aber dringt um hier
wirtschaftlich weiter wachsen zu können
und an dem Wachstum hängt nch mal der
Wohlstand also es bedingt sich schon und
es ist man kann es auf diese Formel
verkürzen ja Sicherheit Verlässlichkeit
ist ja sowieso so zwei schlagworte die
wir heute von der Forscherin und den
Forschern mehrfach gehört haben sie
werfen ja auch der Bundesregierung vor
z.B zusätzlich zu verunsichern
interessanterweise gilt den Fachleuten
da etwas was aktuell ja heftig
diskutiert wird nämlich der
industriestrompreis als Teil einer ich
zitiere
subventionslotterie zu Gunsten einzelner
Branchen das heißt die Raten eigentlich
eher ab davon die raten davon ab weil
sie natürlich die Sorge haben wenn du es
den einingibst kommen die nächsten um
die Ecke wollen auch was haben
grundsätzlich muss man mal zu Subvention
sagen sie sind immer ein teures Mittel
vielleicht auch deswegen dass die
Wirtschaftsforschungsinstitute sagen da
gibt es besseres wie sie ohnehin mit der
ampelregierung teilweise hart ins
Gericht gehen auch das heizungsgesetz
gefällt ihnen nicht viel zu kurz
gesprungen viel zu kleinteilig immer
wieder Änderung das verunsichert
Menschen Unternehmen und verunsicherte
Menschen und Unternehmen die investieren
nicht die konsumieren nicht und deswegen
tritt man dann wirtschaftlich auf der
Stelle dann gucken wir frag noch auf die
Inflation niedrig Stand seit
Kriegsbeginn haben wir schon gesagt aber
es gibt immer noch Inflationstreiber
auch da gibt's eine spannende Studie äh
die sagt die Inflation ist auch deswegen
da weil manche Unternehmen in bestimmten
Branchen einfach kräftige Gewinne machen
und sehr sehr viel Geld einstecken und
damit die Preise treiben und da werden
interessanterweise die Baubranche
genannt
die wie wir wissen gerade wieder nach
staatlicher Hilfe ruft das Gastgewerbe
wir kennen das wenn die die Pizza
plötzlich doppelt und dreifach so teuer
wird Handel Verkehr Flugpreise werden
fast zum Luxus gut auch das ist
überrascht nicht mehr das nennen die
Fachleute
gewinninflation gearflation gearflation
sogar muss uns da als Verbraucherin und
Verbraucher das Messer in der Tasche
aufgehen na ja gut teilweise sind die
Branchen die die Nachholbedarf hatten
nach Corona Flugverkehr oder auch die
Gastronomie und die greifen dann halt zu
jetzt wo sie es können und bei der
Baubranche natürlich fol kommen richtig
die haben auf blendende Jahre konnten
die zurückschauen ähm die haben in der
Tat zugegriffen weil sie es konnten
weils der Markt hergegeben hat und die
Studie sagt tatsächlich es sind nicht
die gestiegenen Kosten die
Lohnstückkosten sondern es sind die
Unternehmensgewinne die äh rasant
gestiegen sind und das hat zwei Aspekte
das hat natürlich einen ökonomischen
Aspekt weil die auch die Inflation die
teurerung wiedertreiben diese
Unternehmensgewinne und es hat natürlich
auch ein moralischen Aspekt auf jeden
Fall herzlichen Dank Frank betmann für
diese Analyse heute Abend hier bei uns
danke dir unser nächstes Thema
Deutschland hat den Weg freigemacht für
eine grundlegende Reform des
europäischen Asylsystems mit dem sich
der Kontinent wappnen will gegen neue
flüchtlingskrisen sprich die Maßnahmen
gegen Schlepper und illegale Migration
sollen härter werden die Asylverfahren
schneller kritiker sagen die Standards
würden sinken insbesondere die deutschen
grün hatten Bedenken gegen den
sogenannten Krisenmechanismus durch den
Mitgliedsstaaten die Rechte von
Migranten erheblich einschränken können
wenn besonders viele von ihnen dort
ankommen Isabel schfers
erklärt alles scheint ganz klar als die
bundesinnenministerin zufrieden aus den
Verhandlungen kommt sie verkündet eine
Einigung im aktuellen asylstreit wir
haben uns heute im Rat politisch
verständigt auf eine
krisenverordnung sie haben das glaube
ich schon mit
nur Polen und Ungarn haben sich dagegen
ausgesprochen Deutschland habe sogar
Verbesserungen rausgehandelt z.B die
Verfahren von Kindern und deren Familien
an den Außengrenzen sollen priorisiert
behandelt werden wirklich in trockenen
Tüchern ist der neue Kompromiss wohl
doch noch nicht unter anderem Italien
soll nun Bedenken haben aber auch andere
sind nicht überzeugt offiziell bleibt
der Ausgang der Sitzung
wage es gibt keine wesentlichen
Hindernisse mehr es gab eine breite
Mehrheit für den
wir werden in den kommenden Tagen eine
Einigung
erziehen es wird nach vor darum gerungen
und derzeit kann mir keine Zustimmung
vorstellen es geht um die sogenannte
krisenverordnung kommen besonders viele
Flüchtlinge könnten die Mitgliedstaaten
mehr von ihnen länger unter
haftähnlichen Bedingungen an den EU
Außengrenzen festhalten das wollte die
deutsche Bundesregierung eigentlich
nicht mittragen doch nachdem der Druck
zu groß wurde brachte der Bundeskanzler
seine Koalition in die
Spur die Regierung ist sich auch einig
darin dass es
äh nicht an Deutschland liegen wird wenn
der letzte Baustein des
Gesamtwerkes nicht auch noch auf den Weg
gebracht wird auch die Grünen mussten
letztlich Einlenken die Außenministerin
verkauft das heute als Erfolg die
letzten 48 Stunden haben gezeigt wie
wichtig es ist bis zur letzten Minute
als deutsche Ministerin für deutsche
aber auch eben für europäische
Interessen zu kämpfen doch mit jedem
Zugeständnis an die deutschen Bedenken
kommen neue Bedenken bei denen auf die
sich härtere asylregeln wünschen auf
Abschottung setzen und die sind in
Europa derzeit in der Mehrzahl
europäische Migrationspolitik zwischen
Ethik und
Pragmatismus ich finde das richtig dass
Deutschland sich viel Gedanken darüber
gemacht hat dass
man Migranten dass man assuchende
menschlich behandelt
und das ehrt Deutschland aber allerdings
sind wir in einer Situation ohne diesen
Krisenmechanismus dass dieser Chaos
weitergeht auch dieser scheinbar
pragmatische Ansatz wirgt neue Hürden
denn das Europaparlament muss der
asylreform auch noch zustimmen und lhnt
viele der geplanten asylverschärfungen
ab wenn man jetzt im Rat immer etwas
beschließt ohne zu gucken ist das
überhaupt kompatibel mit dem was das
Europaparlament will dann wird es
wahrscheinlich eher eine weitere
Blockade geben in den kommenden Tagen
wird sich zunächst zeigen ob es
tatsächlich eine Einigung unter den
Mitgliedstaaten gibt und wie viel Ethik
und wie viel Pragmatismus sich in der
europäischen Migrationspolitik
durchsetzen
kann Friedrich März der cduf ist
Oppositionsführer im Deutschen Bundestag
das ist kein ganz einfaches Amt weil man
anders als die Regierenden nicht
wirklich durch Taten wirken kann sondern
vor allem die Worte bleiben sprich wenn
März Kanzler werden will was ich ihm
jetzt mal unterstelle dann müssen die
Leute über ihn reden über ihn und seine
politischen Ideen und das idealerweise
positiv gestern hat Friedrich märz in
einer Diskussionsrunde bei den
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von welttv
folgendes gesagt die werden doch
wahnsinnig die Leute wenn die sehen dass
300.000 Asylbewerber abgelehnt sind
nicht ausreisen die Vollen Leistungen
bekommen die volle Heilfürsorge bekommen
die sitzen beim Arzt und lassen sich die
Zähne neu machen und die deutschen
Bürger nebendran kriegen keine Termine
was sie hier machen ist eine Katastrophe
für dieses
Land warum tut märz das was bewirkt ein
solcher Satz und vor allem stimmt der
überhaupt die Analyse jetzt von mattes
feldthoff als Friedrich März der Wind im
Plenarsaal so richtig ins Gesicht bläst
zieht er sich erst einmal auf die
Hinterbank zurück wieder eine
intervieussage wie wieder eine scharfe
Formulierung und wieder eine Provokation
für die Ampel diesmal zum Zahnersatz von
geflüchteten die
Aussagen des Kollegen märz den ich
gerade nicht sehe aber eben war noch da
die er gestern gemacht hat sind objektiv
falsch und menschlich niederträchtig
meine Damen und Herren was man nicht
machen darf in dieser Situation und was
die Lösung erschwert das ist wenn ich in
Talkshows noch Öl ins Feuer wenn ich
populistisch Versuche Stimmenfang zu
machen Friedrich märz in den Augen
seiner Kritiker ist er ein
Wiederholungstäter einer der gerade in
der Migrationsdebatte mit unter übers
Ziel hinausschießt vor einem Jahr hat er
ukrainische Flüchtlinge verdächtigt nur
des geldeswgen zu kommen wir erleben
mittlerweile einen sozialtourismus
dieser Flüchtlinge nach Deutschland
zurück in die Ukraine nach Deutschland
zurück in die Ukraine dafür musste er
sich später entschuldigen doch zu seiner
Aussage über junge männliche Migranten
und ihr Verhalten in der Schule steht er
bis heute und dann wollen Sie diese
Kinder zur Ordnung rufen und die Folge
ist dass die Väter in den Schulen
erscheinen und sich das verbitten
insbesondere wenn es sich um Lehrerinnen
handelt dass sie ihre Söhne die kleinen
Paschas da mal etwas zurechtweisen da
fängt es an was treibt ihn warum diese
Härte schließlich versucht die Union
gerade einen Pakt zur Migration mit
Kanzler zu schließen und fühlt seit di
Wochen kaum Resonanz wir haben auch den
Tag 22 an dem von dem Bundeskanzler
nichts mehr über den deutschlandpakt zu
hören war keine Initiative kein Gesetz
keine Gespräche die Union springt heute
ihrem Chef zur Seite der
Gesundheitspolitiker Tino Sorge betont
dass Arzttermine auch wegen der
Belastungen durch Migranten vieler Orts
knapper werden ist eine Realität und
seine Kollegin Jana schimp gesagt wir
haben die Pflicht das auszusprechen was
ist selbst sein parteiinterner Rivale
Hendrik wüst wollte anders als zuletzt
nichts Falsches in der märzussage gehört
haben diese Überlastung sehen wir an
vielen Stellen in Kommunen auch in den
sozialen Sicherungssystem ich glaube das
ist das worauf Friedrich Merz Hinweisen
wollten darauf so habe ich ihn
jedenfalls verstanden aber hat März
insbesondere bei der angeblichen
Zahnsanierung von geflüchteten
tatsächlich recht Zahnärzte Präsident
Benz widerspricht dass ich ete
massenhaft in Deutschland die Zähne
machen lassen wie Friedrich März gesagt
hat das geht im Regelfall nicht März hat
wieder mal einen Ton gesetzt in eine
Debatte in der vor allem die lautesten
gehört werden ob es zur Lösung beiträgt
ist allerdings schwer
umstritten ja es ist keine ganz einfache
Faktenlage die in einem schmissigen Satz
nicht adäquat abzubilden ist umso mehr
lohnt sich der genauer Blick in die ZDF
heute App wie werden Asylbewerber beim
Arzt versorgt und welche
bekommen abgelehnte Asylbewerber dort
finden Sie weitere
Informationen und jetzt hier bei uns
haben wir die weitere Weltlage im
Überblick den hast du Hanna Deutschland
hat eine Vereinbarung über den
milliardens schweren Kauf des
israelischen Raketenabwehrsystems arow 3
besiegelt Verteidigungsminister
Pistorius und sein israelischer
Amtskollege galant unterschrieben dazu
eine Absichtserklärung das System soll
Deutschland und seine Nachbar Länder
besser vor möglichen Raketenangriffen
schützen und ab Ende 2025 eingeschränkt
einsatzfähig sein der Kauf ist eine
Reaktion auf den Krieg Russlands gegen
die
Ukraine ja und das Thema Luftabwehr ging
es auch heute bei einem überraschenden
Treffen von NATO Generalsekretär
Stoltenberg und dem ukrainischen
Präsidenten selenski in Kiev selenski
forderte mehr Unterstützung der NATO um
die Energieinfrastruktur des Landes vor
russischen Raketen zu schützen
Stoltenberg versprach sich bei den
Verbündeten dafür einzusetzen zudem
sagte selenski es sei nur eine Frage der
Zeit bis die Ukraine Mitglied der NATO
werde das Land tue alles um diesem
Schritt näher zu
kommen angesichts der Personalnot in der
Pflege hat der Deutsche Pflegerat
umfassende Reformen gefordert um den
Beruf attraktiver zu machen müssten
Pflegekräfte mehr Befugnisse bekommen
sagte die Präsidentin des Rats Vogler
auf dem deutschen Pflegetag zudem
forderte sie weitere Lohnerhöhungen etwa
ein Einstiegsgehalt von 4500 €.
Bundesgesundheitsminister Lauterbach
erklärte sein Ministerium arbeite
aktuell an einem Gesetz um die
Verantwortlichkeiten von Pflegekräften
auszuweiten im Prozess um den Mord an
der 14-jährigen eilen ist der Angeklagte
zu lebenslanger Haft mit anschließender
Sicherungsverwahrung verurteilt worden
wegen Mordes und versuchter
Vergewaltigung der 30-Jährige Angeklagte
hatte die Jugendliche im Internet
kontaktiert ist sexualisierte
Nachrichten geschrieben und sie massiv
unter Druck gesetzt sich persönlich mit
ihm zu treffen dann ermordete er das
Mädchen der Fall ist ein Beispiel für
das sogenannte cybergrooming das
anbahnen von sexuellen Kontakten mit
Kindern und Jugendlichen im
Internet der heutige Tag markiert eine
historische zesur in einer Gegend dieser
Welt gerade mal vier Flugstunden von uns
entfernt in der kaum jemand von uns mal
war und die dennoch seit Jahrzehnten die
Nachrichten beschäftigt wie hier meinen
Kollegen Wolf von Lojewski im
heutejournal
1992 guten Abend liebe Zuschauer wir
haben es ja nun ausführlich gefeiert und
erwähnen sollten wir es auch hier Heinz
rümann indem wir die bescheidenen
leiseren Seiten an uns selbst erkennen
möchten ist 90 Jahre alt geworden das
gibt dem Tag mal eine andere Perspektive
und dann auch gleich wieder bergab Bach
ein Konflikt zwischen feindlichen
Nationalitäten deren schon so oft
beschäftigt hat setzte neue blutige
Rekorde Bergkarabach auch heute noch und
wieder Thema aber eines mit
Enddatum die selbsternannte Armenia
Republik Karabach mitten in
Aserbaidschan hört auf zu existieren
nach drei Jahrzehnten einmal weil
mittlerweile fast zwei Drittel ihrer
Einwohner nach der jüngsten Niederlage
gegen Aserbaidschan geflohen ist
Richtung Armenien und dann weil die
Behörden der Armenia in Karabach heute
bekannt geben sämtliche ihrer
Institutionen dort würden aufgelöst
arminörper über blutige Geschichte und
unsichere Zukunft im Kaukasus an einem
denkwürdigen
Tag an ihrer Seite nur noch
Hilfsorganisationen die geflüchteten aus
Bergkarabach in Armenien notdürftig
versorgt Haus und Heimat verloren Welt
und Schutzmächte haben sich abgewandt
heute haben sogar ihre politischen
Anführer verkündet dass ihr
selbsternanter Staat aufhören soll zu
existieren ich habe doch gekämpft für
diesen Staat sogar Medaillen erhalten
das kann doch nicht sein aber wir haben
unsere Toten zu betrauern ich kann
nichts mehr sagen unsere Jungs sind
dafür gefallen wenn das alles vorbei ist
wofür dann nur unsere armen
Jungs
Armeniens Regierungschef Nicole pashinan
ihm bleibt heute nur die Anklage an die
Untätigkeit der
Welt die Worte mit denen die
internationale Gemeinschaft die
ethnischen Säuberungen verurteilt sind
wichtig aber solange ihnen keine Taten
folgen sind sie nichts als der Versuch
sich selbst vor der Geschichte
reinzuwaschen und die Geschichte ist
lang und blutig in den 90er Jahren kommt
es zum Krieg Armenien und Aserbaidschan
kämpfen um
Bergkarabach es wird vertrieben verletzt
gehasst und gemordet von beiden Seiten
am Ende 50.000 tote den stat
Bergkarabach den die Armenier ausrufen
wird die Welt niemals anerkennen die
aserbeidschaner verlieren ihre Heimat
und schwören Rache Hass hält sich 2020
wieder Krieg hinter Aserbaidschan steht
die Türkei und Armenien steht Russland
die Hoffnung der Armenier in
Bergkarabach wir können nicht mehr mit
den aserbeidschanern Zusammenleben ich
glaube nur an Gott und an
Russland heute wird er von
aserbeidschanern wie eine Trophäe
vorgeführt Ruben
waranan bis Februar war er
Regierungschef der Republik Bergkarabach
pikant der man war vor seinem Amt hier
Russe und einer der reichsten noch dazu
doch den russischen Pass hat er
abgegeben und der Kremmel hat die Seiten
gewechselt und lässt ihn mit samt seinem
miniaturstaat einfach
untergehen wir befinden uns in einem
neuen Koordinatensystem wir sind im
Kontakt mit unseren Partnern in
Aserbaidschan und verfolgen besonders
die humanitäre
Lage die Geschichte ihres Staates geht
zu Ende ihre Zukunft kennen sie nicht
die Welt hat sich abgewandt von der
selbsternannten Republik Bergkarabach
deren Existenz sie 32 Jahre lang einfach
hingenommen
hatte der Berg ruft um Hilfe alterpruch
heute wieder beklemmt aktuell aus der
Schweiz melden Sie das drohende Ende
ihrer Gletscher dieses und das letzte
Jahr hat deren Volumen um 10% schrumpfen
lassen damit ist in 2i Jahren so viel
Eis verloren gegangen wie in insgesamt
30 Jahren zwischen 1960 und 90 und noch
eine Zahl die aufrütteln sollte die ull
gradgenze lag Ende August in den
Schweizer Alpen bei nie zuvor gemessenen
5300 m so hoch ist kein Berg in Europa
überall in den Schweizer Bergen lag die
Temperatur also über dem
Gefrierpunkt was all das für die
Alpenwelt bedeutet und für uns Menschen
zeigt Elisa
Miebach eine Eis und geröllawine am
marmulatgletscher in den Dolomiten Rei
Menschen in den
wenn Gletscher schmelzen können Berge
ihren Halt
verlieren jedes Jahr misst Geograf
Florian has die Veränderungen in den
österreichischen Alpen und hat Reste von
geröllawinen an schmelzenden Gletschern
beobachtet man kann sich ganz gut
vorstellen dass so ein Gletscher der in
so einem engen Tal liegt dann auch die
angrenzenden hänge stabilisiert wie so
ein natürliches Fundament und wenn
dieses
Fundament einsinkt also wegschmilzt dann
können solche Felswände durchaus auch
kollabieren
die Alpen ein Hotspot des Klimawandels
die Region hat sich seit 1900 schon um
bis zu 2° erwärmt viel schneller als der
Durchschnitt weltweit die glscher sind
wenn man so drüber fliegt und sie sich
anschaut schon in einem ziemlich
erbärmlichen Zustand mittlerweile gerade
diese kleinen Gletscher da im hollachtal
sind schon noch wirklich kleine Reste
die übrig sind Florian ha dokumentiert
das Schmelzen des Eises das mal für ewig
gehalten wurde ja für ja ab den 90er
Jahren geht's steil abwärts mit den
Gletschern also das kann man auf jeden
Fall sagen und es ist natürlich eine
Folge der Erwärmung und das Eis
verschwindet nicht nur sichtbar auf dem
Berg sondern auch im Berg hier auf etwa
2800 m Höhe kontrolliert Ricardo
scandrolio regelmäßig den sogenannten
Permafrost wir sind in der Mitte von der
Zugspitze in der Mitte vom Berg wir
haben ungefähr 50 m Fels oberhalb von
uns und in die Richtung sind noch 20 m
bis zum steile
Nordwand hier bleibt es so kalt dass ein
großer Teil des Eises auch im Sommer
nicht schmilzt es hält das Gestein des
Bergs zusammen wie Mörtel eigentlich
aber ja also diese Bereich langsam
Tauern schon auf man sieht dass Eis auch
hier weniger wird also das das ist schon
auch hier zu spüren die Berechnung der
Wissenschaftler zeigen in 50 Jahren wird
es den Permafrost in der Zugspitze nicht
mehr geben wen die Erwärmung begrenzt
wird gibt es nur für das Eis in den noch
höheren Bergen Hoffnung und das
schmelzen würde dann überall verlangsamt
wenn wir sagen wirben wir bleiben bei
1,52° Erwärmung dann passieren alle
diese Prozesse viel langsamer und das
heißt je langsam der Klimawandel
passiert desto langsam auch diese
Prozess in den Berg passieren und wir
haben mehr Zeit die zu verstehen die zu
vermessen und nicht zu vorher zu sagen
und das kann Leben retten denn nicht
alle Berge der Alpen sind so gut
überwacht wie die
Zugspitze und später im heute journal
Update eine gletscherforscherin und ihre
Eindrücke was ich da in den Alpen
abspielt und wie sich das Wandern in den
Bergen für uns alle verändern wird jetzt
erstmal hier bei uns noch mal du Hanna
der right livelyhood Award auch
alternativer Nobelpreis genannt geht in
diesem Jahr unter anderem an die
europäische Hilfsorganisation SOS
mediterrane sie erhalte die Auszeichnung
für ihre Lebens such und
Rettungseinsätze im Mittelmeer wie die
preisstiftung heute bekannt gab
ausgezeichnet werden außerdem die Ärztin
und Frauenrechtsaktivistin brookman
amissa aus gana die kambodschanische
umweltaktivistengruppe Mother Nature
Cambodia sowie die kenjanische
Umweltschützerin
omido viele kennen ihn aus dem Harry
Potter Verfilmungen in der Rolle des
Albis Dumbledor nun ist der
irischbritische Schauspieler Michael
Gamben im Alter von von 82 Jahren
gestorben in sechs Harry Potter Filmen
verkörperte Gamben den Leiter der
Zauberschule Hogwarts der theaterfernseh
und Filmschauspieler galt als äußerst
vielseitig und schlüpfte in seiner mehr
als 50 Jahre währenden Karriere in die
unterschiedlichsten Rollen vom
biblischen stammeskönig bis hin zum
neuzeitlichen
Verbrecherboss in Köln werden zur Stunde
die Auszeichnungen des diesjährigen
Deutschen Fernsehpreises verlienen unter
den bisher bekannt gegebenen Gewinnern
sind auch Produktionen des ZDF so hat in
der Kategorie beste Moderation
Einzelleistung Information der freie
Journalist Ginzel gewonnen ausgezeichnet
wurde Ginzel für seine ZDF
Berichterstattung über den Krieg in der
Ukraine für die beste Sportsendung des
Jahres bekamen unsere Kollegen aus der
Sportredaktion den Fernsehpreis für ihre
Berichterstattung über die Fußball WM in
Qatar ja Gl Wunsch allen Gewinnern auch
von uns allen hier beim heute journal
auch an die Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Mitbewerber aus Hamburg die Tagesthemen
haben auch einen Fernsehpreis bekommen
für die beste
Information so vom Bauen hatten wir es
gerade schon es ist auch ein Thema
natürlich für und bei maybrett ilner
Bauen Sanieren mieten kein Plan gegen
Wohnungsnot Fragezeichen das gleich hier
im ZDF Programm und später gibt's dann
un ser heute journal Update gegen 0:30
Uhr mit Christopher whmann vom gesamten
Team auch den Kolleginnen und Kollegen
hinter den Kameras ein angenehmen Abend
[Musik]
tschüss herzlich willkommen zum Wetter
ungewöhnlich warm ist es zurzeit in
weiten Teilen Europas das reicht von
Russland bis hinüber nach Spanien wo wir
auch heute wieder Temperaturen um 35°
erreicht haben selbst im südenenschweden
sind das im Moment um die 20° bei uns
eben um
25° wir schauen uns jetzt mal an wie das
über das Wochenende verläuft am Samstag
bekommen die Temperaturen bei uns
nämlich einen kleinen Dämpfer aber dann
kommen schon neue Warmluft aus Richtung
der ibärischen Halbinsel zu uns an dort
könnten wir dann in den ersten
Oktobertagen auch neue Temperaturrekorde
verzeichnen bei uns ist auch die Nacht
recht mild mit Temperaturen zwischen 11
und 15° im Süden kann es auf 7° Abkühlen
denn hier ist es oft klar stellenweise
bildet sich Nebel aus Nordwesten kommen
jetzt immer mehr Wolken ins Land in der
zweiten Nachthälfte beginnt es zwischen
dem niederrehein und Schleswig Holstein
auch schon etwas zu regnen das ganze
kommt dann morgen weiter in Richtung
Osten und in Richtung Mitte voran bringt
viele Wolken mit und auch ein böhig
auffrischenden Wind dahinter folgen dann
neue Schauer und eventuell auch mal ein
kurzes Gewitter alles in allem kommt
aber nicht viel vom Himmel und
zwischendurch gibt's auch immer trockene
Phasen im Süden kommt die Kaltfront
morgen noch nicht an da gibt's nach
Nebelauflösung noch einmal viel Sonne
und das sorgt für große
Temperaturunterschiede morgen an der See
gibt's teils keine 20° in Richtung
Lausitz und im Süden sommerliche 25 bis
29°. am Samstag verabschiedet sich der
September dann mit den Resten der
Kaltfront im Südosten und wie gesagt
etwas kühler am Sonntag in den ersten
Oktobertagen machen sich dann schon
wieder die spätsommergefühle im südenit
im Norden ist es etwas unbeständiger und
damit auf
Wiedersehen